Okay, folks. Um, how many of you are
going to be gone next week, the spring
break?
You take your DCF to the beaches with
you or the bars or wherever you are, you
know, or maybe take your Tesla valuation
around, you know, conversation piece,
right? So, today we're going to talk
about valuing companies and I'm going to
call it, you know, the dark side of
valuation. Sounds ominous, but it's
about valuing companies where valuation
is difficult to do. And let's face it,
that's what this class is really for
because companies are easy to value.
Let's face it, you don't need this
class, right? Mechanical, you just
extrapolate the past. So, I'm going to
set up the process today because these
are some of the issues we're going to
run into. We talk a lot about corporate
governance in corporate finance and in
many ways we've lost our way on it
because we talk about boards of
directors and independents and Sarbay
and Oxley but let's talk about corporate
governance from a valuation perspective.
Let's say you have a company which has
poor corporate governance and I'm going
to let you in your mind decide what that
means. Let's say the firm is badly
managed.
You've done a discounted cash flow
valuation of this company and come up
with a discounted cash flow value of a
100 million for the company. Everybody
with me so far? But there's bad
corporate governance. Should you be
discounting the 100 million for bad
corporate
governance? What do you think? Wow.
Yeah. And how do we know it's embedded?
Because you did the DCF, right? So in a
sense, if you do the DCF, you did the
cash flows and it's badly managed, you
reflected that in the cash flows, it's
already there. If somebody else has done
the DCF, don't assume it's already in
there, right? You got to ask them
questions. But if you do your intrinsic
valuation
direct, what if this were a
well-managed
company? You saying, shouldn't it be the
same? I'm going to come back to you. If
it's a well-managed company, should I be
attaching a premium to the company?
The problem with well-managed companies,
you build in the fact that it's well
managed to the cash flows, right? But if
it's bad corporate governance, what it
what's hanging over your head, do
well-managed companies stay well-managed
in
perpetuity? Not
necessarily. Maybe the people managing
the company now might pass on. the next
generation might not be as strong or the
person running the company kind of goes
from being a good manager to a bad
manager. It's a challenge you face when
you value well-managed companies where
you worry about corporate governance.
you might actually overvalue the company
if you don't factor in the chance that
at some point in time. I mean it's for
the last 20 years this has basically
been the thing that troubled me the most
about the great tech companies right
starting with Google what have they done
they've skewed the corporate governance
game by issuing voting and non- voting
shares so when you bought Google in 2004
or Facebook in 2012 you might have
thought about the people running the
company then as being great founders
great
managers but there is always a chance
right and then after the fact of course
you wake up and say I at a tet discount.
It happened in m with Facebook after the
metaverse
fiasco. But corporate governance is
tricky because it's not just locking in.
So bad management we can actually deal
with. But good management I think you
always have to say what is the chance
that that could change. So we talk about
corporate governance. Second made a big
deal about capitalizing R&D. Actually,
you didn't, but I I did, and I made you
make a big deal of it because you had to
do it in the quiz, but your heart might
not have been in
it. So, let's say you take a farmer
company, you take conventional
accounting. You know what I mean by
conventional accounting, right? The
traditional accounting statements, the
R&D is expensed. You value the company
and you come up with a value per share
of
$20. Then you go in my spreadsheet, you
just say yes to the R&D, you capitalize
R&D, and I magically change all your
numbers, right? Your earnings get
restated, your return on capital gets
restated, your sales invested capital
gets restated. But my question is about
the bottom line. Ultimately, we care
about value per share. Will my value per
share remain the same? Because money
spent is money spent, whether it's
capital expense or operating
expense. If you believe
that, then what should we be doing about
R&D? It's doing nothing to value per
share. Why are we wasting our time?
Right? So if I believe that I wouldn't
have spent the 30 minutes or 45 minutes
making you go through that torture. So
clearly that's not the answer. So now
I'm the question if I capitalize R&D for
a pharmaceutical company will my value
go up because I have higher earnings or
will my value go down because of higher
reinvestment or could the effect be
different for different
companies? What's it going if if it's a
if it's D what will it depend on?
Anybody want to give that a
shot? When right with I'm
sorry. When we capitalize R&D, what are
we doing? We're bringing it to the same
level as every other investment, right?
And what's the effect of an investment
on
value? It's a good investment. It'll
increase value. And the way we measure
good is is the return on capital you're
making on the investment greater than
the cost of capital. In a sense, we're
bringing R&D to that same test. Now I'm
going to come back to you. So when you
look at a former company and I
capitalize R&D, will R&D increase or
decrease value? And if so, what will it
depend on?
Capitalize R&D is to bring your the
earnings. So we know the effects.
Earnings will be up, return invested
capital down, reinvestment will
increase. So the effects are mechanical.
But why might the effect push up the
value in some companies and push down
the value in others? Gabrielle success
if it's good not even if it's success.
We have a portfolio of R&D if on average
you are good at doing R&D. R&D by itself
is neither good nor bad. Just like
innovation is neither good nor bad.
Right? You can talk about innovation in
a society being great but in a company
innovation makes sense only if you can
create value from it. R&D is good only
if you can create value. What we're
doing is we're separating the good R&D
companies from the bad R&D companies.
I'm going to show you my value for
Amchen. So way back in time a couple of
years ago their capitalizing R&D
increased the value per share. I also
valued Merc at exactly the same
time and guess what the effect was
there. This is a company that has spent
a hundred billion dollars in R&D and has
very little to show for it a decade
later. and my valuation will reflect the
fact that you're doing R&D. You're
throwing good money after bad money
trying to make money
back. And that's the reason we
capitalize R&D because we need to ask
that question about a company. We take
it for granted. I think we, you know, I
blame business schools that R&D is good,
innovation is good.
Teslas research lab, R&D is good. That's
your job. But if you're a business, your
job is not to do R&D for the sake of
doing R&D. That R&D is to convert into
products and earnings and cash flow.
Sounds incredibly
mercenary, but that's what a business
is,
right? Funding. When talk about distress
companies, what when we say distress,
what are the pieces that go into a
distress
company? Money making or money losing?
Usually money losing. And if it's
distress, usually there's a lot of debt
overhanging the company. And I ask you
to value a company. You know the
mechanics of how to fix a distressed
company in a spreadsheet, right? What do
you have to do? You've got to grow the
revenues out, make the negative into
positive, bring the debt. It's all easy
to do on a spreadsheet. And you do it
all the
way we we go through the mechanics. And
by the time you're done, what do you
have? You have a nice money-making
company with a sustainable debt ratio.
So, and you're in year 10, you put a big
terminal value, you discount it all
back, and you get a value of a billion
dollars for the equity. Job well done,
right? You fix the problems on the
spreadsheet. I think that even if you've
done everything with reasonable numbers,
you've overvalued the equity in the
company. Why is that,
Jacob? What have I missed?
Do everything. Hard is never the reason,
right? Hard is basically tech. It's not
just that it's hard. This is the value.
If the company makes it back to
health and becomes a viable company, but
if it's a distressed company, what's
hanging over their
heads? They might not make it. And you
know what? You can't bring that into a
discounted cash flow valuation. I know
you're saying, "But the D, I can raise
the D. It's not going to work." Discount
rates are blunt instruments. They were
never designed to deal with truncation
risk. Risk that a company will not make
it.
you will overvalue distress companies in
DCFS because you're ignoring the very
real probability that these companies
will not make it and that is tough to
bring into DCF. So today we're going to
talk about what to do with distress
companies and in your mind I want you to
start thinking about what am I missing
chance that they'll go bankrupt how do I
bring that into valuation and I want you
to think decision
trees remember that two branches and in
a sense that's going to be the basis for
how we're going to think about this or
any other discrete risk. So, lots on our
plate. Let's get the process
rolling
by setting up the dark side
evaluation. So, I'm going to go back to
the very first session of this class
where I talked about what drives value.
You know, the intrinsic val first two
sessions. When we think about intrinsic
valuation now, we think of Excel
spreadsheets. We think about inputs. But
basically there are four questions
you're asking and answering about a
company to value. First is what are the
cash flows you're generating from your
existing
investments. Your answer could be
nothing. It could be huge. It could be
negative cash flows of existing assets.
Second question is what is the value
you're going to add or destroy? I should
have added that word by trying to grow.
Why add or destroy? Growth is a good
thing in terms of increasing revenues
and earnings. But growth also requires
reinvestment. The net effect can be
positive, negative or neutral. Third
question is how risky are your cash
flows? Notice I'm stating these
questions generically. I'm not asking
you what's your beta. I mean you can
have different measures of risk but
fundamentally you still have to bring
risk into your c into your discount
rate. And finally ask when will you be a
m mature company. Joe why do I need the
answer to that? Because then I can put
them into stable growth. When those at
the risk of stating the obvious when
those questions are easy to answer,
valuation becomes
easy. So when do you think these those
questions are easy to answer? What kind
of
company? Mature company. Let's keep
going. Mature company in a business that
is not being disrupted because you could
be a mature company in the automobile
business and guess what? The whole world
is coming apart under you with a long
history and a management team that is
kind of in there and kind of locked into
whatever they're doing. You're valuing
Coca-Cola. The questions are easy to
answer. But when will those questions be
difficult to answer? With young
companies. Why? Because they're still
being
formed. With companies that don't fit
the accounting mold. The first time I
wrote this, I misspelled mold as a mold
that grows underneath. I'm still not
sure whether it's M O L D or Mold. I
think this is the right version of mold.
Don't fit the accounting mold. In what
sense? Well, a manufacturing company,
everything works the way it's supposed
in accounting. Any company other than a
manufacturing company, you're
stretching, right? You've got to
capitalize things. You got to expense
things. And finally, companies that face
significant truncation risk. We talked
about one distress. What else could
cause truncation? I know I had a student
of mine who lives in Venezuela still has
a business and he called about valuing
his business. I said, "What the he the
thing he's most concerned about is that
his business is doing too well." I said,
"Why is that concerning you?" He said,
"We're doing so well. The government is
watching us." And I said, "Why is that
concerning you?" Said, "Because they
might decide to nationalize the B
business." And when you get
nationalized, I'll tell you one thing I
can guarantee you. You're not getting
fair value. You might get book value,
half of book value or nothing. He said,
how do I bring that into the valuation?
And you can think of variance of this,
right? Discrete risk, nationalization
risk, regulatory
risk. So, we're going to talk about all
of those companies. So, I'm going to set
the table on the kinds of companies I
want to cover in this section. First in
today's session, I want to range across
the life
cycle. I'm going to start with my
favorite part of the life
cycle, young companies. I may be
strange, but I like dealing with
uncertainty. I like facing up to
uncertainty. I like looking at things
where everything hasn't been set in
place yet. I feel like I can tell the
story. I could be wrong, but so is
everybody else. So, we're going to start
with young companies. Second step, we're
going to look at mature companies, but
where there's something significant
happening underneath an activist is
challenging them and they might
restructure. The business is
changing. And finally, I'm going to look
at declining companies. And I'll be
quite honest, I don't like valuing
declining companies. They make me feel
like I need to take a shower every five
or seven minutes. You value brick and
mortar retail companies in the US. There
is no happy story, right?
It's going to be a horror story. The
only question is how much carnage, how
much blood before the whole thing runs
out. So companies across the life cycle.
Then I want to talk about across
markets, emerging market companies. I've
seen entire books on valuing emerging
market companies. I don't get
it. The value of a company is a value of
a company. Cash flows, growth, and risk.
The fact that you might face challenges
in getting growth rates and discount
rates doesn't mean mean you write an
entire book on how to because then you
create your own rules as you go along.
I'm not going to but I'm going to talk
about the things you deal with with
emerging market companies that aren't
unique to them but still might be
specific to them. And finally I want to
talk about valuing companies across
sectors. I'm going to focus particularly
on banks. And I'm going to tell you
something about how I thought about
valuing banks before
2008 that I have to get over. In all of
my books that were published before
2008, I have either a section or a
chapter in valuing banks that starts
with a line that I've never been able to
live down. It says, "Valuing banks is
easy." And I'll talk about the
assumptions I made before 2008 that led
me there. and why those assumptions
don't hold anymore. how I value banks.
Now I want to talk about valuing
commodity
companies. Think what's unique about
them? What's a what's a feature about
commodity companies that makes them
messy to value? Even a mature oil
company, Michael, what is it? They don't
control the price. The the biggest
factor, the uncertainty you have is not
about the management, the reserves. It's
about the oil price. It's a macro
variable. It's an outsider in your story
that you don't control. It's like that
eccentric alcoholic uncle who pops into
the story, changes the story and walks
away and you don't know when he will
show up. So, we're going to talk about
what to do with companies where there's
a macro risk component. And finally, I
want to talk about, you know, the
pharmaceutical companies. I'm going to
take AMS and show you how the R&D effect
plays out and why we spent the time that
we did. So, let's start with young
companies and Constantine, you're going
to be my guinea pig here. You've started
a very promising AI business. You just
started it last week. Lots of promise
and potential, right? So, I'm going to
ask you the four questions about your
company that I need to know the answers
to and try your best with given that
this form. First, what are the what's
the value of the what are the cash flows
you get from your existing assets?
Nothing. You don't even know the chair
you sit in, right? That was easy. We get
that out of the way. There's nothing
there. What's the value of future
growth?
A lot. Don't say anything. You're the
founder. You got to say a lot. Said
beyond that, how much more can you say?
You don't know the market. You don't
know your product. How risky are you?
Very. But beyond that, what can you do?
You can't show me past history. And I
ask you when will you be a mature
company? You fall out of your chair
laughing. You don't even know whether
you'll make it through next
week. Now, do you see why most people
don't even try to value young companies?
Every question becomes incredibly
difficult to answer. That's the excuse
VCs give for never valuing young
companies. Too much uncertainty. I don't
know what the answers
are. So, I'm going to set the table on
why young companies are so
problematic. As when we value companies,
we're constantly looking for crutches.
You know what I mean? But crutch is
something to base our numbers on because
then we can blame somebody
else if the numbers go up. So what's the
first thing we look at? We can look at
the company's current
financials. That 10K becomes almost a
bible. You go through it, you reverse
it, and you read it backwards. You read
it forward. You get AI to read it to
you.
You What are you looking for? Clues on
growth and profitability and
reinvestment. Then you look at the
company's history. What are you looking
for in the company's histories? Is it
cyclical? Is it risky? Is it
volatile? And then to console yourself,
you also look across the industry. What
are you learning there? You're learning
what happens to margins as companies
grow and scaling
effects. You look at the company's
financials. You look at its history. You
look at its comparables. One by one, I'm
going to knock your crutches out. You're
valuing a young company in a business
where every company looks just like your
company. They're all young, unformed
companies. So, your financials tell you
very little, right? You're a young
company. What am I learning by looking
at your financial statements? You have
no history. So, that's gone. You look at
other companies, they look just like
yours. Congratulations. You've hit what
I call the valuation
trifecta. You have no
crutches. And some of you are valuing
companies like these where you say, "I
have nothing to base my numbers on."
And that's when the dark side will
beckon. What does the dark side look
like? It says, "Oh, the old rules don't
apply. That making money, it's so 20th
century. Cash in, cash out." That's not
what we look at
here. You invent metrics that nobody's
seen
before. In fact, the example that I just
gave, young companies, every company's
like your company. In the 1990s, what
was I describing? the dot companies,
right? Every company young, unformed,
what were the metrics that were
invented? Anybody remember, Michael? How
many times someone viewed their web?
Market value per website visitor. And
then Mary Mika said, "That's not
sophisticated enough." Mary Mika was a
morgan.com analyst became a legend in
the decade. She said, "It's not just how
many people, but how long they look at
your web page." She created market value
per eyeball.
Here's the problem with these metrics.
If I told you the market value per
eyeball is 250 and I asked you, is that
a high number? Is that a low number?
What's your reaction? I really like my
eyeball. 250 doesn't sound like that
much. Maybe it's even cheap. The problem
with these metrics is you have no frame
of reference. And when you have a metric
where there's no frame of reference, you
have no idea what's high, what's low. So
you pay whatever everybody else has
paid.
And every company you confront about why
you worth a lot. What's the answer you
get? A macro
story. Is going to be incredible.
Everybody's going to be on social media.
And right now with AI, every AI company,
what's the justification they offer? The
AI business is going to be huge,
trillions of
dollars. And this is the
pathway to insanity, right? Basically,
nobody's asking questions. I let you use
the big story. Use metrics that nobody's
seen before. Get away with
it. In the 1990s, when I used to do
these sessions, peak of the.com book, I
would do a session on discounted cash
flow valuation. The end of the session,
somebody would come up to me very
aggressively and say, "You really cannot
value Amazon.com using a DCF model, can
you?" And the way you knew what answer
they wanted to hear, which is no, you
can't do it. You do whatever you want.
And at the risk of grave personal
injury, I would say no, you can value
Amazon with a discounted cash flow
model. And they'd give me this look of
total contempt. It's a
academic. That's not meant as a
compliment, right? You know what the
what the subtext there was, right?
You're an academic. You can talk about
this stuff. I have to do this for a
living. And after the fifth or sixth
time of being called an
academic, I got really pissed off and I
valued Amazon for the first
time. I'm not going to show you my very
first valuation of Amazon from 97. But
I'm going to show you my valuation of
Amazon from January 2000 because as I
said at the start of this class,
everything I know about valuation I
learned in the
context of valuing Amazon. You're going
to see the birthplace of the FCFF simple
Ginsu model when I value Amazon. So, let
me set the stage. January 2000 was the
peak of the dotcom boom. The NASDAQ had
just hit
5,000. Nobody saw the cliff coming.
Don't don't let them lie to you and I
saw this in December 25th. I was doing
an analysis. No, you just didn't see the
cliff coming. and Amazon.com was the
poster child for the dot boom. So, A
IMR, which is the parent organization
for the CFA, came to me and said, "Would
you be willing to do a webcast?" It was
a very primitive version of a webcast
then on how to value Amazon. They set up
the camera up on the 11th floor. They
had to have a whole crew in those days
to create a webcast.
So, I'm going to give you a compressed
version of my valuation of Amazon and
use it as a vehicle to talk about the
things I learned while valuing Amazon
that I still go back to when I have to
value a Palunteer or the next generation
AI
company. Coming into 2000, Amazon had
$1.1 billion in revenues. Let me pause
right there. Is that a lot of revenues?
1.1 billion for a retail firm in the US
is minuscule. Just to give you a frame
of reference, $1.1 billion in revenues
in 2000. Walmart at $250 billion. The
GAP had 17 billion. This was a tiny
retail
company and was losing $410
million. The cast is set, right? You've
got small revenues and big operating
losses. So I'm going to ask you a
question which I started with in this
process. Is it possible that a company
with small revenues and big operating
losses, is it possible for that company
to become a valuable
company? Yeah. At some point in time,
every company is a company. So play it
out. It's simplistic. Da what has to
happen to my small revenues? I have a
high growth rate. So I need revenues. I
need big revenues. The growth rate just
gets me there, right? I made my small
revenues have to become big revenues and
my losses have to become
profits. Simple as that, right? You see,
this is so incredibly simplistic. That's
where I started. How do I get my small
revenues to big revenues? I use a
revenue growth rate. I estimated a
compounded annual revenue growth rate of
42%. I'll come back and explain why 42,
why not 45? Why not 39? And I hadn't
even finished saying
42%. When the first push back comes in
those in that webcast, people had to
email their questions. They weren't
directly they were listening in. But the
first question that comes in is how come
you're being so pessimistic about future
growth? I said pessimistic. I'm making a
billion in revenues into 41 billion. I'm
increasing your revenues 40fold. But you
know why it sounded pessimistic? What
were they comparing the 42
center revenue growth rate in the most
recent year which for Amazon was 200%.
So the question they were asking why you
bring what they missed was the
compounded in the 10 years. I wasn't
using 42% in year one. I was using 150%.
But as I went through time those growth
rates decrease because scaling is an
ugly beast. It kind of pushes down your
growth rate. So I thought I was being
upbeat. It's an upbeat story I'm making.
I still have to justify why, you know,
why why did I end up with 41 billion?
Why not shoot for 200 billion, 100
billion? I'll give you my story then.
But this is part start of an upbeat
story. They're losing money right now.
Minus 36.7% margins. Let's ask an answer
the easy question. What'll have what's
the value of Amazon if their margins
will stay at minus 36.7%
forever? They're going to crash and
burn. they're going to go bankrupt. So,
let's get that out of the way. I put my
optimist hat on. I'll be quite honest.
If you're a natural pessimist, don't
value young
companies. You'll always end up with
zero. Yeah, you find a pathway to zero.
So, I put my optimist hat on. I liked
Amazon as a company in 2000. I like the
way Jeff Bezos was making
choices. So, I did assume that they
would succeed as an online retail
company. Let me be very clear. In 2000,
I saw them as a retail company. I'll
talk about my subsequent valuations of
Amazon, what's changed
since. And I gave them an operating
margin by looking at successful retail
companies, all of which were in the
brick and mortar
space. I went to the 75th percentile of
margins of retail companies already. You
can see the upbeat story building up,
right? 40fold increase in revenue, 75th
percentile of margins. That's a 10%
margin. So I'm going to move the margins
from minus 36.7 to 10. I'll talk about
the intermediate steps I used to get
from 36.7 to 10. But my company is now
taking form and my spreadsheet is a
large money making company. There's one
final lette. No to get my revenues from
a billion to 41 billion. It's not going
to happen effortlessly. They'll have to
reinvest. Reinvest in what? I have no
idea. Jeff Bezos had no idea. This is
not about you asking man. And this is
why when people say can I ask management
can I talk what exactly are they going
to tell you right they're in a business
everything is changing it be
acquisitions it could be computer
platforms it could be logistic centers
but the one thing I do know is growth is
not going to be free they'll have to
reinvest and this is where I got stuck
on this valuation the longest how do you
estimate reinvestment for a young
company I looked at every textbook
including mine and tried to do it, but
none of it worked. I said, why don't I
take last year's capex and depreciation
just
extrapolate? Who knows what last year's
numbers even look like? I'd be
projecting out things that you could not
even sustain. You could look for
industry averages, but remember the
online industry averages on capex as a
percent of revenue depreciation or all
over the place. And ultimately, what's
my what's my driver that that drives
growth? It's revenues, not income. So, I
knew that I needed to connect how much I
reinvested
to how much my revenues are growing.
Hence was born the sales to invested
capital ratio. It's a ratio that exists
in accounting. It's called a turnover
ratio but they use it for a different
purpose. Here I'm bringing it as a proxy
for this is what I'm going to use to
estimate reinvestment. And the nice
thing is it's connected to growth cuz
left to their own devices what do
founders and managers want to do give
you higher growth rates and I'm going to
be the skunk in the room said that means
you got to reinvest more. And that I
think is a reality check kind of
restraining that number. I used to sales
to capital ratio of three saying where
did that come from? I looked at Amazon's
own history. There's a partial history
of how they've grown and they've been
very efficient about growing because
they use supplier capital off to fund
their growth. I also looked across
retail firsth not just online retail and
there again I went to the 75th
percentile saying they can invest more
efficiently than a traditional retailer
because they don't need the brick and
mortar stores and that sales to capital
ratio is three. That's going to be the
driver for reinvestment. So we'll talk
about the reinvestment each year but
it's very simplistic. Here's my advice.
When you're valuing on companies, keep
it
simple. Less is more.
adding line items and just create chaos
when there's no need for chaos. So
what's in that reinvestment? Everything
capex, acquisitions, R&D, it's all
consolidated in that month. Adil, you
had a question.
How did you make that 75?
It's your story, right? 90 would make
them a really special retail company.
Generally, when you get to the 90th
percentile, you're talking about niche
retail companies, luxury retail
companies. You're not going to get there
if you're going to be a general
retailer. So, you got to bring in the
common sense perspective of where to put
them in this based on the business model
you give them. It's got to be consistent
with your own story,
right? So, my losses become profits. I
put in the reinvestment. You agree? It's
a pretty upbeat
story. Take a look at my free cash flows
the firm in my upbeat story. My free
cash of the firm in year 1 is - 933
million. Year two is minus a billion.
Year three is minus a billion. Year four
minus min - for the first six years I
have negative cash flows.
Why? Because my story is so upbeat. The
more upbeat your story becomes, the more
negative your cash flows will become.
Doesn't make them bad, doesn't make them
good. It's just what it is.
And there is an assumption I made in
2000 that in hindsight I was a little
too casual about. You have negative cash
flows of about a billion each year for
the next three years, right? What do you
need to do? Raise capital to keep going.
And in 2000, I'd be quite honest, a dot
company needing to raise a billion
capital. That's pretty easy.
I ignored the possibility that even if
my numbers came in exactly as expected
that the capital markets would shut down
because if that
happens, you're not going to get to year
10 and the terminal value and all that
meat stuff. So maybe in hindsight, I
should have put in a failure rate, but
in 2000 I was not building in failure
rates into my DCFS because I didn't know
any better.
So in my repeat story, Amazon makes it
through the worst of times, raises
capital and the value that I got for the
for the assets is 15.2 billion. I add
cash, there almost no cash. Shows you
how confident they felt about being able
to raise money. I subtract out debt,
almost no debt, which makes sense.
They're a money losing company. I'm
almost done, right? I've got a value for
the equity. And then I subtracted
out employee options. Now, do you see
why I made that stop over and say, "What
do we do about the dead weight cost of
giving away options like free currency?"
They've given away pretty much a quarter
of the company cuz they were so free
about issuing options to managers, to
employees. And though that equity is not
under my reach as a common stockholder,
I take it out. I divide by the number of
shares. I get a value per share of $35
with every one of my valuations. I'm
going to ask let you ask me the question
after I'm done with the valuation. The
question is going to tell you whether I
believe my own valuation that I have
faith. My value with my upbeat story is
35. The stock is trading at
84. Ask me the question.
Clearly I'm not buying right. Did I
short? And this was exactly the question
that the webcast ended
on. I was almost going to turn off the
webcast and say, "Oh, we ran out of
tape." In those days, they had no idea
how this was being recorded. But I gave
them the answer. I said, "Not in this
lifetime."
And of course the followup is do you not
have enough faith that I'm I was more
convinced that Amazon is overvalued in
January 2000 than I've been in most
companies I've bought which are
undervalued over the last 20 years. So
why am I unwilling to put my money
behind my words
the market has to converge but you can
say that about buying as well. So
complete the thought. It has to
converge. But when I buy, when does it
have to converge?
By sell time arises where I can wait. I
can wait it out, right? But when you
sell short, what do you do? You borrow
other people's shares and you agree to
return them
when? Whenever they ask you. So I did
call around this. You could see this
question coming a mile away. So I asked
around with brokers as to how long they
would give me if I sold short. 6 weeks
was the most I was able to get because
in early 2000.com stocks were in such
high demand. 6 weeks. Now do you see why
I said not in this lifetime? Not only do
I have to feel confident that Amazon is
overvalued, I have to feel confident
that the correction will happen in the
next six weeks and there is zero chance
I'm doing that. And that points to one
of the great asymmetries in investing.
When something is undervalued, there is
a long-term buy and hold bargain
basement strategy. It requires a long
time horizon, but there are people out
there with it. When something is
overvalued, there's often not an
equivalent long-term way of taking
advantage of your point of view. It's
better now than it was 20 years ago. You
have some some stocks have leaps, which
are long-term put options, but in
general, it's much more difficult. So,
what does it mean? Bubbles when they
form will be far more likely to be
upside bubbles than downside
bubbles. Do you think housing is
overvalued in 2007? What exactly are you
going to do? Sell your neighbor's house
short? I don't even know how this works.
Can I borrow your house for a couple of
months? But there were people who are
creative about trying to take advantage
of it. Right? I teach two of my classes
in a room that is funded by one of those
people. How did John Pollson make money?
He basically found a way to short
housing by using traded securities as a
vehicle. It required a lot more work
than of obviously going long but that
was the advantage. Very few people did
what he did and the 4 billion of three
billion or whatever he made paid for
that room and a lot more in. So if you
find overvaluation, it's much more
difficult but not impossible if you can
find a creative way to take advantage of
it. And to discount these cash flows, I
forgot to mention I needed costs of
capital. Key word is costs of capital.
Why cost of capital? Is my company
changing over the 10 years? It's going
from small money losing to big money
making,
right? And if I'm being consistent, what
should you see in my cost of capital? A
high cost of capital up front, 12.8 84%
almost entirely equity funded and by the
time I get to year
10 cost of capital reflects a much more
mature company 9.61% 61% cost of
capital. Be internally consistent. This
is not about something you want to do to
this is your story and your discount
rate should reflect your story. So, what
I'd like to do is take that Amazon
valuation and kind of dig in a little
deeper and talk about the lessons I
learned from this valuation that I still
bring to valing young companies. First,
remember what I said about betas? I said
don't trust regression. Betas that goes
in spades when you're valing a young
company.
And here's why. This is the Amazon
regression
beta from 2000. So there's a 2.23 raw
beta. If you keep going down, there's a
standard error of the beta. Can you
read? It's kind of fuzzy. What does it
say, man? No, no, it's the standard
error. That's a standard
dev, right? So my raw beta is 2.2. My
standard error is
0.5. Think about what I've just told
you. The true beta for Amazon can be
anywhere from 1.2 to 3.2. into it's
insanely noisy. There's nothing you
could learn by running a regression. So,
how did I get the beta for Amazon? I
used a bottom up beta, but I used two
sets of companies. For the first five
years, I used the bottom of bait of
online retailers, arguing they higher
fixed cost, they're younger, there might
be other issues, but then by the time I
get to year five, you got $15 billion in
revenues and you're making money. you're
now retailer first who happens to be
online and move the beta towards a
retail beta.
You're allowed are you allowed to do
that valuation you know it's up to you
to justify what you're doing but
essentially it's principal driven you
can essentially define bottom up based
on the company second and this was the
the big page in terms of that 42%
compounded growth and the 10%
margin when I first valued Amazon I
valued the way we're all taught to value
companies which is work sequentially you
know I remember sequentially you do year
one then year two then year three. The
This is how most discounted cash flow
valuations go. And I discovered that as
I went from year one to year two to year
three, I was getting more and more into
this. I have no idea. I'm getting So, if
I kept doing this, I'd have pulled all
my hair out by the time I got to year
seven. So, I said, "This isn't working
for I'm going to step back and I have to
rethink how I forecast cash flows." So
what I'm going to s say next is going to
sound mildly Deepak Chopraish. I hate
the guy. So kind of take the deep. To
value young companies, you almost have
to visualize what a successful version
of that company will look like. He said,
"What the heck are you talking about?
What's my story? That they're going to
be an online retail company, right?" So
what does a successful online retail
company look like? And you know how I
got the answer? I went and looked at the
20 largest retail companies in 2000.
The largest was Walmart. And I walked
down the list and I said, "Where on this
list would I expect to see my vision of
Amazon show up 10 years from now?" You
think that's subjective? Of course, it's
subjective. Everything in valuation is
subjective. Get that on the table, knock
it off, and then go back to estimating
things. I said, "Will it be as big as
Walmart and my 2000 vision of Amazon?" I
said, "No, they're not a discount
retailer. They're not going for low
margins, high revenues." I said, "Will
it be as small as an Taylor?" I said,
"No, it's more than just a pair of I
went back and forth and I finally put
them between the fifth and the six
largest retailers in the
world." She went fifth and sixth, not
third and fourth. It's my story. You
want to make it third or fourth, make it
your story, right? I don't own the
story. This is my story. My money is
riding on it. I'm going to make the
choice. And guess what? The revenues in
the fifth and sixth largest retailers
and inflation adjusted basis was about
41 billion. 40 and 42. I went right down
the middle 41 billion. So I know my
starting number 1.1. I know my ending
number has got to be about 40 billion.
See, how did you come up with all these
growth rates? I'm made them up. You
didn't mislear me. I just made them up.
And if you made a big deal about any of
those numbers, I'll concede it to you.
So in year one, you say, I think it's
163.35%. You can have that. You want
year two, you can have that, too. If you
let me control the ending number, I
control this
valuation. So in young companies, big
disagreements are about the endgame.
What do you think this company can
deliver in steady state, not about the
year 1, the year 2, year three
numbers. So that's how I got my revenues
from 1.1 to 41
billion. Then let's turn to margins. My
starting number is minus 36.7. I want to
be to 10. And I'll tell you the one
thing I did not want to do. I didn't
want to be estimating year one margins,
year two margins, year three margins.
Again, it would have driven me crazy.
So, I turn my spreadsheet on autopilot
and said fill in the middle. But I had
to give it some guidance. So, I gave it
an algorithm and I'd like you to guess
what that algorithm is that allowed me
to get such precise
margins. How do I get
-3.35
minus 1.68 +
4.16? Anybody want to give that a shot?
How do you think I got this number?
You're taking the end number and
you're subtracting it out from the top.
Okay. So, I start so let's work it
through. My starting number is minus
36.7. What do I want to be at the end?
10. What's the distance between the
two? 46.7. I took half the
distance to my goal. I'm at
-3.35 when you get to half the distance
for you're saying why half the distance
why
not when I design valuations I designed
them for people to disagree with
me what is this half share it's it's a
part of my story about the pathway to
profitability right and it's a pretty
smooth pathway to profitability but
let's say you agree with every other
part of my story and this is the part of
my story you don't agree with you say,
"Look, it's going to be a lot more rocky
than you think." You know what you
should do, Da? What should you do to the
half? Make it a quarter. What does it
do? It'll You lose money for a longer
period before you turn things around. If
you're really upbeat and optimistic, set
it to one, in which case, what'll
happen? You go from - 36.7 to + 10 next
year. It's the simplest device. like I
could have set some exponential
lognormal function but then you're
saying that what do I do to this to make
it move in the direction. So when you
set these adjustment factors on
spreadsheets set them in a way in which
people can see what's happening. It's
pretty transparent and you can change
it. So my loss myus 36.7 becomes + 10.
And as my margins go from negative to
positive my losses become profits. The
last column, I've computed the after tax
number. In the first two years, I lose
money, so I have no taxes. In year
three, I make money, but I still don't
seem to be paying taxes.
Why? Cuz I track my NOL and I keep it in
my cash flows. I've seen bankers often
take NOLs and set them to the side and
after they're done with the valuation,
do all kinds of gymnastics about what do
I do with the NOL. The value of an NOL
is very simple. It saves you taxes in
future
years if you make money. It's in my cash
flows and I don't have to worry about
NOLs as long as I can track them. That's
why in the Genu spreadsheet you'll see
that NOL line item. Most of you are not
using it. If you have a money-m company,
you're money losing company ask you for
the starting number and then as you lose
money that starting number will get more
big to the NOL will get bigger and then
when you start making money I apply it.
And as I'm doing all of this, I have
that 10 year horizon. Every time I value
young company with potential, I get
challenged on the 10 years. And you can
see what the challenge is, right? Why
only 10 years? And especially when you
have a company like Amazon, we have the
benefit of
hindsight. Well, you've known it's grown
for 25 years. It seems incredibly
pessimistic. So, I'm going to start with
the reality check. 2000, I don't know
who the winners and losers were. I liked
Amazon. So I had to look at what I knew
then and I all what I knew then was how
long growth lasted a typical growth
company. And I'm going to give you the
results of a study done of IPOs a few
years ago by somebody at Wharton where
they track the revenue growth in IPO and
compared it to the growth of the peer
group. So one year after the IPO, the
IPO's revenue growth is 15% higher than
the peer group. See, that's good. I
bought a growth company. Two years
later, that difference is down to 7%. 3
years later, it's down to 3%. By the
time you get to year four or five, you
can't tell that IPO apart. Most growth
companies growth fades three, four, five
years. And I've used 10, which is
already at the 90th
percentile of growth periods for most
growth companies. Do some companies grow
longer than 10 years? Of course, the
90th percentile, there's a 10% that grow
longer. Why am I not incorporating it?
Because as an investor, I need something
for myself. If I put in a 50-year growth
period, and I justify today's
price, that's like signing a young
baseball player at 19, expecting him to
hit 50 home runs for the next 19
seasons, right? If you pay him that much
up front, then if he hits only 40 home
runs, that's a negative surprise. If he
lasts only 17 years, that's a negative
surprise. So, I'm going to stop at 10
years. are very seldom pushed past 10
years. The exceptions are sometimes with
pharma companies where you've got a
patent that takes a really long time to
kick in but have a good reason for
expanding past the 10 years. Yes.
Matter in this because they're looking
maybe
doesn't matter. I mean this study looks
at IPOs across time. So that shouldn't
be a factor. It's not one IPOs in a
particular year. It's IPO spread over
time. Good markets, bad
markets. And all that we said about grow
paying for growth in the context of
traditional growth applies when you look
at young companies. You know why people
believe that somehow when you come to
young companies, you don't have to think
about any of those things anymore. So
the reason I put in that sales to
capital ratio is to hold you
accountable. You want growth, you got to
reinvest to create that growth. It does
make my life easier that I've used the
sales cap because all I need to do is
take the change in revenues and divide
by three. And I do that every year. If
there's a lagged effect, it's actually
very easy to build in, right? Take the
change in revenues in a future
year and compute the reinvestment there.
So, year three will drive reinvestment
year one. Year four will drive
reinvestment year two. Sales to capital
ratio is just your starting point for
reinvestment. And you can build in all
kinds of adaptability into
it. And as I'm doing this, my
spreadsheet is actually giving me
feedback if I'm willing to listen.
Because think of what I've done. I've
projected out the margins and operating
income in future years. Right? I'm
computing reinvestment based on sales.
Remember, reinvestment becomes your
delta, your invested capital. It's a
change in invested capital. So, I keep
track of what your invested capital is
going to be based on what I'm
reinvesting. I have after tax operated
income coming from margins and growth,
reinvestment coming from sales to
capital. If I divide the income by the
invested capital, I get a return on
invested capital. It's an imputed
number. It's coming from my assumptions.
You're saying so what what's my return
on capital in year 10 for Amazon?
20.39%. The question I'm asking myself
is can I live with that? Is that a
company that I think and 2000 I felt
okay with it? Because the average retail
company was making 18%, I was giving
Amazon a slightly higher return on
capital. But let's say that return on
capital year to be
200.39%. What's my spreadsheet telling
me? you're not reinvesting enough,
right? And if I'm listening, what should
I do? I should go back and revisit my
sales to capital ratio and reduce it to
make my return capital a number that I
can actually live.
Yeah. Is there a possibility that sales
per capital ratio can change? In fact,
it can change over time, but it has to
be something to do with the business
model, right? Is it getting easier to
grow as you get bigger? In some business
it might be. Is it getting more
difficult to grow as you get bigger? You
might have to go to less attract to
markets market. So it depends on the
story and the business you're in. In
this case, I didn't have any adjustment
because retail business is huge. But if
you were looking at another business
where as you grow, you're entering
either less attractive markets or
there's some networking benefit that
makes you
stronger. You build it in. So it doesn't
have to be a constant. In fact, the
Ginsu spreadsheet, I give you two
chances to do the sales cap. One for the
first five
years and then for the next five years
because the next five years we want to
bring it up. So think those are the
things you think about whether you
should let those numbers be different
numbers. Is is this business going to
allow me to invest more efficiently for
like economies of scale for example?
Yeah, it's see but this is not econ
economies of scale are operating margin
questions. They're really not invested
capital questions. This is about what do
I need to create growth. So you can't
use an economies of scale argument for
sales to capital ratio. It's got to be
something to do with business models and
what you're investing into growth.
Professor, yes. In the Ginso
spreadsheet, the years to pay off is
either one, two, or three. If I want to
enter like seven, eight or nine for a
farmer, can I do it in that? You can. I
mean, in a sense, a spreadsheet just
takes in typical sales, right? So I use
the growth rate to get revenues each
year. You can take the revenues and
replace them with yearby-year revenues
for the next 5 years if you feel that
you're in a position to forecast them
out. So just remember once you hardcode
those numbers, you're kind of locked in.
So if you're going to enter revenues by
year, create a separate worksheet with
revenues by year. Read it. Read from
that worksheet. So when you want to
change your mind, you're not going into
the main valuation spreadsheet and
changing hardcoded numbers. Right?
Because everything in that actual
valuation spreadsheet, none of the
numbers there are hardcoded. Everything
comes from something in your input
sheet. So you want to enrich the input
sheet, go ahead. You can break a
business down to three businesses and
and create three lines for revenues.
It's it's a starting point, not an
ending point. It's an open spreadsheet.
You can go and and adjust.
Yes. Going back to the sales over
capital ratio. Um I'm thinking something
like network effect may be possible like
as the business that could be so
business could get more attractive at
which point Uber might be able to get
more sales per dollar capital in which
case raise the sales to capital ratio as
you go to the second part of the
valuation. I'm also imagining it can
also accelerate the revenue growth. So
the don't double count though because in
a sense if you're going to do a growth
story you've already told your growth
story. This is about what do I need to
invest to get the growth. So you use
networking benefits to push up your
growth. That's fine. But then you got to
tell me how those same networking
benefits are because you're you're
counting on for a second benefit. Right?
Not only are they making you grow
faster, they also make you grow more
efficiently. And that's a different
story that you got to tell, right? With
Uber, that second part of the story
might be more difficult to tell because
the way they grow is they go to a new
city that they fight to get more market
share. So that part of the story might
get more push back
on. Now along the way, is there going to
be some delusion in my story? What are
my cash flows for the first six years?
They're all negative cash flows. And
those negative cash flows will require
more shares to be issued. You're saying,
"How do you know they're shares and not
debt?" Because you look at my debt ratio
for the next five years, it's 99%
equity, 1% debt. I'm telling you what
they're going to use, it's going to be
equity. So I'm confessing there'll be
shares issued in the future. There'll be
options. Those options will get
converted to share. So that's going to
add to your share count as well. And if
you remember, I actually divided the
value of equity by today's share count.
I don't I seem to be in denial about
those future share issuances,
right? But am I?
Why not negative cash? Because those
negative cash flows for the first six
years. Remember that 15.1 billion value
that I got for Amazon's equity by
discounting the cash flows would have
been 20 billion if I hadn't had those
negative cash flows in the first I've
actually reduced my value discounted my
value by 25% because they have negative
cash flows. That's the delusion effect
already in my present value. If I take
that value and divide by this adjusted
share count that counts the shares I
will issue to cover those negative cash
flows, I will be double counted. Same
thing with options. What did I do with
options? I took the value of the
options. I reduced the value of equity.
I agree there'll be options shares
outstanding because of those options,
but I'm not going to count those because
I've already reduced my value of equity
today for the value of the options.
There will be delusion, but I just don't
care because it's already in my equity
value today, my value per share today.
Picture, we should always look at value
per share instead of the value of the
entire
company because you're an investor.
Remember, you're doing this as an
investor, right? You don't buy the
entire company. I don't think unless you
have a lot of money, you know, three
trillion, you get on Schwab or you get
on Fidity and you say, I want to buy a
thousand shares. So ultimately you do
value per share because you compare to
price per share right because leaving it
at the generic equity value is neither
here or not there because what am I
going to do with that as an
investor so you you do have to do things
on a per share basis finally and even if
you're an acquired that's what you buy
right you go buy shares at a particular
price. It's a publicly traded company. I
don't see any way around the fact that
you need a per share value, not just a
kind of collective value for all of the
equity. Now, as I said, I was a little
upbeat in that valuation and not
factoring in failure because we know
failure is a clear and present danger.
The Bureau of Labor Statistics maintains
this I think incredible database where
they track the number of startups every
year around the US broken down by sector
and then they track them every year
afterwards. So this is the 2006 cohort
that they've tracked for 15 years after
the startup. So how do you read this?
Let's take a sector, the retail sector,
right? If you track all of the companies
that started in
2006, 16.9% failed within one
year. 47.9 failed within two years.
That's why those bleeer stores you walk
by two years from now you walk through,
they're not going to be there. Half of
all retail. And if you look at what
percentage of firms make it to year 10,
31% of retail startups make it to year
10. You see, what's magical about year
10? That's when we put a nirvana in a
terminal
value. And this is saying be careful. A
lot of companies don't make it to your
debt. There's a failure risk here. In
2000 when I was building spreadsheets, I
didn't have that in there. And I
realized very quickly, maybe in 2001,
that this was a clear, you know,
sometimes you need a reminder. Hey,
you're missing something big. In 2001,
reminded me of that because I saw
failures all around
saying, why is my value off? because I
didn't factor the failure risk. I'm not
suggesting it's going to be an easy
number to estimate. And once you go
public, the risk drops off fairly
dramatically because you open up sources
of capital. The larger you get, the
lower that number becomes. You know, I
know it's not fair, but you get too big
to fail. All those things will feed into
the failure risk. It'll also affect if
you're valuing a company in a bad in a
capital market where there are lots of
restrictions. you're valuing an
Argentine company, the value tax for the
same company will be lower than in a
market where there is access to capital.
It gives you this number that captures
those risks. So I finished my valuation
and there must have been somebody in the
audience who owned Amazon. She said, "Is
it possible that Amazon is worth $84 per
share?" What's the answer to that
question? Possible is such a weak word.
Of course, it's possible. In fact, I can
tell you how to get there, right? What
are the two big drivers of value?
Revenue growth and margins. If I put in
higher revenue growth, have an end
margin and a higher margin, I'm going to
get there. See these shaded areas? Those
are the combinations that deliver a
value higher than the stock price. At
60% compounded annual growth rate will
make Amazon the second largest retailer.
So, this is embedded in these break even
points are stories. The question you got
to ask yourself is, am I comfortable
making Amazon the second largest
retailer in the world while giving them
the
margins of a more niche retail company?
Because that combination is what you
need to get. And my answer was, look, I
can give you break even points, but I
don't think they're possible, but
they're not plausible or probable. You
can always compute break even points for
any company. It's a good idea to do it
after evaluation to say, "Hey, what does
the number have to be?"
Now, as you're doing all of this,
Julie, these are very unlikely, but I
know you just a couple examples like
Lightning multiple times. And so the
same company mean different companies
that are like oh well what if this
company was worth something but like oh
it actually was 100 worth 100 times more
sort of initiative. Do you remember the
things that lightning did not strike
though? I mean the problem as human
beings is we hold on to memorable
companies. We forget about all I forget
all those dot companies that I looked at
even in the late 90s. Right? So I'm not
saying you're wrong, but I'm saying
sometimes we overestimate the likelihood
of success because the companies that we
remember are the companies that are
successful. We tend to very quickly in
our mind set to the side all those other
companies that we thought were going to
be promising companies that have kind of
faded. I'll wager 5 years from now you
probably say what Pelaton I don't
remember that company but remember that
COVID boom of Pelaton. So I don't
disagree with you. But the question then
you got to ask yourself is what is it
that sets these lightning strikes
companies apart from the rest? And is
there a way I can assess that into one
of the numbers right maybe so someone in
the in the era said like some retail
company will be worth a trillion dollars
like the sector will be worth a trillion
dollars. You'd say well maybe like the
sector will be collectively but like it
seems like you can find like one person
will sort of achieve those wild you know
what early on the assumption was that
one of the existing retailers would end
up dominating just like in the PC
business what is the early bet on who
the winner would be IBM right now how so
sometimes the companies you so right now
I ask you who's going to be the winner
from AI the answer seems obvious right
it's Nvidia it's
Microsoft 10 20 years from now we look
back at it and say who is the real
winner could be very different I mean I
look back at what I thought in the '9s
is early in the '9s Cisco winner you're
going to have AOL a winner that didn't
last very long so I'm not disagreeing
with you that you can make trend B and
that's what Kathy would in a sense
that's her entire strategy right she
picks a trend and she picks a company
that she thinks is going to be the
winner in the trend she her valuation
skills are abysmal right But her trend
spotting skills are really good. So the
question is is was it docu what is it?
What's the company she own? Docu
docuent. One of the companies she owns
and clearly she's on to the trend. This
is a trend. We're going to I mean every
big document I've se signed in the last
two or three years has come through. So
clearly this is a trend. More and more
of our documents are going to be sent
digitally. You need signatures. You need
a company that can back it up. Will docu
be the ultimate winner? he's made that
bet. But I think that that second part
is a lot shakier than the first part. So
I'm not disagreeing with you about
trends and eventual winners, but I think
it's actually a lot more difficult while
you're in that space figuring out who
the end winner is going to be. And you
don't think that like looking at Amazon
in 2000 still talking about years later
like there was something about a special
or in hindsight? I think it's one of the
most amazing companies ever. But that's
the hindsight of having watched it go
through maturing. It looked like it was
maturing as an online retail in 2010.
I'll talk about what changed and how the
story for the entire company changed. I
think it's one of the most amazing
companies in terms of narrative and how
they've shifted narrative over time.
Now, as you're doing all of this with a
young company, what are you saying? I
could be wrong. I could be wrong. I
could be I'd save you the trouble.
You're definitely wrong.
you're going to be wrong 100% of the
time and it's
okay. It's not your
fault, you know, because things will
come out and things about the market,
the
company. And the reason it's okay is you
don't have to be right to make money.
You just have to be less wrong than
everybody else. And it's what brings the
anxiety level down on
companies. In fact, with Amazon, this
played out in real time. I valued Amazon
2000 dramatically overvalued. I said and
I played did the little song and dance
of I can't sell short not time horizon.
A year later for AMR I revalued Amazon
but this time in a very different setup
right the dot boom had
bust and they said can you at this in
2001 the question was will any dot
company ever be worth money again I
revalued Amazon and my value went from
$35 down to about $20 per share you
think that's terrible your value changed
that
much well what did the market do from 84
down to
11 and I was
trapped. You know why, right? What's the
question? Are you buying and now I can't
do any song and dance about time
horizons? I bought Amazon for the first
time in
2001. And here this old nostrm from
value investing of you just buy and
forget. You know the thing about just
buy and hold for don't do that with
companies like Amazon or Tesla or
Nvidia. These are not the kinds of
companies we buy and forget because the
value is changing, the price is
changing. So guess what I had to do in
2002? I had to revalue the company. You
can't take the original valuation and
use it again. And compared to the price,
it was still undervalued. So I held on
to it. 2003, the value actually almost
doubled, but the price
tripled. It's time for me to leave. I
bought Amazon five times in the last 25
years. I've sold Amazon four times in
the last 25 years. So, I've kind of
given you a clue of where Amazon is in
my portfolio right
now, but this is a company I've gone in
and out of because there've been times
when it's been cheap and times it's
expensive. If id held it for all 25,
would I have made more money?
Maybe. But that would not be consistent
with an investment philosophy says, buy
when something is undervalued, sell when
something is overvalued.
As you know, I sold Tesla. Does it mean
I will never own Tesla again? No. At the
right price, I'll come back in, but not
at $230 per share or $225, whatever it
is today, 220, 215, 210, whatever
happens. So, it basically means that
you're you're
adapting. I very seldom do this with
Amazon in 2014. I went and looked at the
actual
numbers and compared them to my
forecasts. Remember my forecast the 2010
number my projected revenue is 41.3
billion their actual revenue is actually
lower 34.2 billion they were
undershooting and then you look at the
margins I projected the margin to get to
10%. Their actual margin was 4.11%.
But they were moving to and I assumed in
2010 that they were now going to slide
take them longer time but they're going
to get to be and then in 2011 the story
kind of broke because the company
started
behaving as if it were back to being a
startup. In what sense? They were
reinvesting more. They were selling at
low closer to cost. Their margins
decreased. The reinvest went up.
And the question I'd ask is, have they
gone
crazy or are they becoming a it's like a
transformer movie, right? Basically, are
they transforming into a different
business? In 2012, the story I told for
Amazon shifted from being an online
retail
company to a disruption
machine. I don't think Amazon can be put
into any business anymore. They're a
disruption machine. What do they do?
They target soft
businesses and then they go for your
softest underbelly. Do they make money?
Not necessarily. When I talk to
companies about Amazon getting into
businesses, look, if Amazon gets into
your business, I don't have any idea
whether they will make money. But I know
one thing for sure. You will all make
less money than you did
before. Which is one reason when Amazon
enters a business, you look at the
market reaction to the other companies
in the business. The day they bought
Whole Foods, the collective market cap
for all grocery store companies, that
includes Walmart and Target, which get a
significant portion of groceries,
dropped by about 30 billion on that one
day. The day Amazon was allowed to
operate in Chile, Chilean retailers lost
25% of their market cap.
So in hindsight, am I going to beat
myself up? I remember presenting this
valuation 2015 in front of a group of
bankers and they one of them puts up his
hand says in 2000 why weren't you
building a cloud business in for Amazon?
I said the only clouds I was thinking
about in 2000 were up in the sky, right?
You can't use the benefit of hindsight
saying why didn't you put an AI into the
Nvidia revenues in 2015? I had no idea
AI was coming in the form it was. You
can only do what you can do in terms of
what you know then. And this is a more
recent valuation. But when I value
companies, I try to visualize something
that'll help me kind of remember the
story. So with Netflix, I think I've
mentioned this before. What I see is a
hamster on a wheel because this is a
company that keep producing content to
get subscribers. To get subscribers, you
get more content. So, I don't know how
you get off the wheel, right? With
Amazon, when I see the company, I
visualize my favorite Avengers
character, Thanos. I like the bad guys.
My grandchildren don't even get this. My
You don't like Captain? I said, I like
Thanos. The guy has death,
right? He's clearly misunderstood, badly
treated.
I mean, I see Thanos and I see the
finger click and I see multiple
businesses going to dust and kind of I
remember that every time I see Amazon
act and I'll tell you the one thing as
an investor in Amazon that could
potentially stop them. It's not another
company. I think head-to-head I can't
think of another company in the world
that can win against Amazon. You can win
against iniches. Costco in a segment of
retail, Alibaba and Chinese online
retail. The one thing that can stop them
is a regulator or a government. And you
know what's going to allow regulators
and governments to stop them is the rest
of their competition will go in front of
the government say you got to save us
from this
monster. And that's going to essentially
be the one thing that that can act as a
check on check on
Amazon. So young companies clearly a
challenge, but you can see that they're
interesting, they're evolving, they're
shifting, and you got to adapt with
them. Let's talk about valuing mature
companies. Mature companies are usually
easy to value because they have a long
history and they're set in their ways,
right? Can you get set in bad ways?
Every morning when I wake up, well, I
have my coffee. I have a Lindsor
tart. Horrifically bad breakfast full of
sugar, lots of
jam, and I'm probably killing myself,
but I'm set in my ways. I guess I like
that lizard part. Do companies have
Lindsart like problems? Yeah, sometimes
as a company you get set in your ways,
and over time those ways have become bad
ways, but you keep doing it. And with
mature companies, the problem is if
somebody else comes and says you need to
stop doing this and they have enough
power to change the way the company's
run, you now have two pathways the
company can take, right? Keep doing what
you're doing, call it the status quo,
and a second way in which they could do
things which could yield a very
different
value. So let's look at how this plays
out the question. Whenever I ask a
question of a company, then you can give
me two possible answers. One is they
keep doing what they're doing, you get a
value, status core value. So what are
your cash flows? What's your growth
rate? How risky are you? When will you
be a mature company? And then I can ask
you a second question which is if you
change and you become a different
company, what will the answers be? And
you get two different answers. Trying to
put both into the same valuation is
messy. So here's what I'd suggest you
do. Value the company twice. Once with
the status quo and once with the So I'm
going to take an example. It's a company
called
Horell. You know what Horell does or
makes? Really disgusting
stuff. In fact, I think they've created
the most disgusting concoction that
passes passes at food. You know what I'm
talking about, Michael? I think so. I
think it's salami and the cheese or it's
No, it's actually spam. Oh, spam is this
meat in a can, I think, which can last
forever. Think about it. Meat that lasts
forever. I don't even want to think
about how you get it
done. But Hormell made the company was
built around spam. So they should have
monuments to spam, a statue of spam or
whatever you need to do. But it's a
company that like many other food
processing companies is spam was
familyowned, became family controlled,
and now the family has moved on and a
foundation for the family actually is
the largest shareholder. But it's a very
conservative
vir. How does this play out? They
reinvest very little and they reinvest
only in the US. Their whole world is the
US is our market. No, let's not look
elsewhere and they don't borrow much
money because they don't like to borrow
money. So status quo low debt ratio,
very little reinvestment. You give them
low growth cost of capital that reflects
a low debt ratio. The value that I got
was about $32 per
share. But could they be run more
aggressively? I think so. One is they
could use a little bit more debt. And
I'll talk about why I picked the 20% as
opposed to 10%. It's not just a higher
debt ratio, low as the cost of capital.
In this case, it did. And I also assume
they could be more aggressive about
their reinvestment. Go for more growth.
Again, I'm not being completely
outlandish. The growth I'm going to give
them is 5.6%, not
55%. Slightly higher growth, slightly
lower cost of capital. The value that I
get is $38. I have two values for the
company. Right? You're a passive
investor. There's only one price. Let's
say it's right in the middle,
$33. It's lower than the status quo,
higher than the optimized value. Which
one are you going to use in
comparison? Depends on corporate
governance, right? If you think you can
change the management, if you think
there's zero chance of changing the
management, you're stuck with the 32. If
you think there's a 100% chance, you
think, what's going to give me that
property? Would it make a difference if
I told you call I can has accumulated
some shares? That would alter your
property to a greater not
guaranteed. In this case, what kept the
property change low was the Horell
Foundation. Largest single
stockholder. The person who ran the
foundation was also the CEO of Horell.
Kind of undercuts any chance that there
would be change here, right? So, I left
the property at 10% and my expected
value worked out to be about
$32.50. Hershey's looked very much like
Hormel until the foundation decided to
be the activist. They said we're not
making much money. Our wealth is all
tied up in this. They actually were the
ones pushing for change. So that's
what's keeping the 10% there is even a
foundation might wake up and say we're,
you know, we're invested in this
company. We want it to be worth more.
Now incidentally for those of you in my
corporate finance class the way I come
up with how much debt a company can have
is not use the lazy assumption of more
debt is always better than less debt
right I've heard that from Carl I can I
remember in 2012 told Apple to borrow
$300 billion and he said you borrow 300
billion it cost you only 3% it's much
cheaper the only thing was that 3% was
the cost of debt the debt that they had
which is like 20 billion you borrow 300
billion more there's zero chance it
stays at 3% your cost of debt will go up
your cost of equity will go up. So what
I effectively do and we've already laid
the foundation for this because the way
we get bas is with an unlevered beta and
a debt ratio is I compute the beta at
different debt ratios giving me higher
cost of equity. I compute a rating for
this company at higher and higher debt
ratios. Not surprisingly as my debt goes
up my rating decreases and I come up
with a cost to capital. The reason I
picked the 20 the 20% debt ratio is my
cost to capital kind of hits a floor
around 20 to
30%. And I said beyond that I'm actually
going to increase my cost to capital. So
that 20% debt ratio really
reflects. Last piece for today dealing
with decline. Let's look at the
question. What are your cash flows from
existing assets? If you're a declining
company, what do you see? Revenue
shrinking margins under pressure. What's
the value of growth? You start laughing.
What growth, right? That was back in the
past. How risky are you? Depending on
what you're devesting and paying off,
your debt ratio could be shifting. Your
business risk could be shifting. You
when will you be a mature company? He
said that was 20 years
ago. Now I'm just hoping to just
survive. So one of the challenges you
face when you're valing declining
companies is if those companies
declining revenues and shrinking
margins, they're run by sensible
management. What's the pathway you
should adopt? Get smaller. Shrink and
see if you can survive as a much smaller
company. If they're run by ambitious
people, visionaries, God help you. A
declining company run by a visionary is
a recipe for disaster,
right? Because then you're going to make
ambition to become a young growth
company. You're going to do
acquisitions. You could drive even that
limited value declining company is to
zero and below. So you have to take a
stand on who's running the company and
look at the management say are they is
the question I ask myself when I look at
Intel now it's a declining company maybe
it can find its way
back I'm going to be looking at the
actions taken in the next few months to
see what pathway they're going on
because I don't want them to be go back
to being TSMC or try to be Nvidia they
can't do that
anymore so when you value a declining
company that becomes the factor so I'm
going to take an example of Bed Bath and
Beyond. When is the last time any of you
were in that godforsaken
place? I remember the first time I
walked in. When you say bed, bath, you
expect what? Clothing and sheets and
towels. You walk in, this is the beyond,
I guess, catches all the rest of the
stuff, right? You walk in, there's a
refrigerator in the front, there's
furniture on the side. It's like a
department store gone crazy, right? with
no organizing principle. But for a
while, it was one of the fastest growing
retail concepts in the US. I mean, I
know lived a few miles away from the
original Bed Bath and Beyond store in
Springfield, New
Jersey. It's like a destination. It's
like the last Blockbuster video. I think
it might still be around. Visit it, walk
in, and you're going to very quickly see
why the concept died the way it did. So
this is a valuation I did at Bed Bath
and Beyond where I valued the company.
This was like two years ago. Its base
year revenues were 7.9 billion, but
they'd been declining over time. So I
said, you know what, I don't see an
endgame here where they're going to go
back to growing in the near future. I
actually continued with the decline. I
made them a much smaller business and I
said, you can maybe become a niche
business with some people who like this
concept, but it's going to be a much
smaller bit. Over time though I did
assume that their losses would converge.
So I'm in my story I'm essentially
making them a smaller niche company with
margins they can sustain the value per
share that I got
was you can work out the value somewhere
other 3.3 billion for the equity but
remember this is a declining company
with a lot of debt. There is this very
real chance that they will not make it.
The way I incorporate that with a broad
and a risk of
failure. How did I get the risk of
failure? I got lucky. They had a rating
and if you have a rating, I can back
from the rating what the chance of
failure is. And given the rating, you
know, was I think single B B+. I looked
across and there's a S&P and Moody's
both update these studies. How many of
those companies within each ratings
class make it to year 10? It's a 24%
chance of failure. What will my equity
be worth if they fail? I can almost
guarantee that it'll be worth
nothing. You take the expected value,
the value per share I got was 323. The
stock was trading at
879. Of course, it's now the equity is
worth nothing. The company's pretty much
done, but I was trying to value
declining and you can see why your story
is going to be, you know, the story of
shrinkage and hope. In fact, in some
cases, you shrink the company and you
got liquidated at the end of year five
or 10. There's no end game here. So with
declining companies, it's really that
psychological effect of how do I now
when I talk to people who do valuation
for a living, I ask them a very simple
question. When was the last time you
valued a company and put in a negative
revenue growth rate? You know the answer
usually is I've never done it. Which is
interesting, right? Because there are
companies that shrink. How come you
never run into these companies? So leave
open that door. And one final thing is
even if you do things reasonably in the
evaluation you get a DCF value there is
this very real chance of failure you got
to bring in you're going to over so you
almost have to complete the process an
estimated likelihood of failure and what
you will get as an equity investor if
you fail so I know I'm hitting the clock
here but I'm going to show you a
valuation I did a company called Las
Vegas SDS familiar with this casino
company and I hate to generalize.
Actually, I love to generalize, so I'm
going to generalize anyway. Casino
companies tend to be run by
megalomaniacs. This is my anecdotal
evidence. You take Wind Resorts, you
know, and this is a company run by a guy
called
Sheldon, company that grew a lot in the
2000s and then 2008 hits and the bottom
falls out. They have huge amounts of
debt. So, when I did this valuation, I
valued them at $812. I fixed them on the
spreadsheet by doing what? Increasing
the margins, reducing the debt. I made
them a healthy company, but there were
stories swirling around that they might
not make
it. So, I finished the valuation. I come
up with 812. I fixed the company on my
spreadsheet. The stock price is 425. So,
they'll ask me the
question, my buyer said, I'm not even
tempted. Which led to some soul
churching, which is what am I missing?
And the answer is this $812 is the value
for Las Vegas Sands if it survives and
gets back to health. And all the stories
around me are saying it might not be the
case. So estimated property of default
and this will be the last thing for
today by doing two things. One is doing
what I did for Bed Bath and Beyond using
the rating to estimate it. But Las Vegas
science also had bonds outstanding and
there's an interesting way in which you
can back out from a bond price. the
chance of default. You know the price of
the bond, you got the coupons and the
face value. You can solve for the
likelihood of default by just
discounting it the risk-free rate and
saying what is the chance I would not
get the and the answer that was truly
terrifying. The bond market was telling
me there's a 77% chance that Las Vegas
hands will not make it. You take an
expected value in both approaches,
you're bringing in the fact that your
equity is going to be worth nothing.
They default. So with distressed
companies, that's why I have that
failure risk number. So if you have a
company that's distressed or young and
you want to bring in the risk of
failure, bring in through that. So I'm
going to end on that note because you
have everything you need to value a
company. So you across life cycles. So
be creative. Don't be afraid to be wrong
and make your best choice.
circle. Bless.